winter Andrews died just 23 minutes
after she was born her death the result
of serious errors during her birth that
left her brain starved of oxygen she was
her parents first born they came to
court to see the hospital find 800 000
pounds after admitting criminal charges
no Financial penalty will ever bring
winter back sadly we are not the only
family harmed by the trust's failings we
feel that this sentence isn't just for
winter
but it's for all the other babies that
have gone before and after her
widespread failings in maternity care at
the Nottingham trust are under
investigation and more than 900 families
have now contacted a review it's being
led by a senior Midwife who says staff
shortages are a problem in maternity
units around the country we're more than
2 000 midwives short but of course the
maternity team is made up of anesthetist
Obstetricians neonatologists and so on
and I talk to those team members across
England pretty much every day of the
week and what they say to me is is they
are often overworked on their knees
despite hundreds of serious cases it's
still rare for Regulators to bring
criminal charges against a hospital
this is only the second time an NHS
trust has faced a criminal prosecution
for maternity failings and it's the
largest fine for errors in maternity
care
the trust has apologized to Winter's
family we accept the failings we accept
today's a ruling of the court and we're
now very much focused on improving the
services but he says Moore still needs
to be done to guarantee safe care for
mothers and babies Becky Johnson Sky
News Nottingham